pour les résidents de ce quartier de
Kiev le réveil a été brutal
vitro brisée véhicules pulvérisés au
pied des immeubles les pompiers ne
ménagent pas leurs efforts
pendant la nuit une impressionnante
salve de domicile et de drones kamikaze
russe est abattu sur la capitale
ukrainienne les habitants sont en état
de choc
j'ai entendu une explosion très forte
très forte nous avons rapidement sauté
du lit et nous avons vu une voiture en
feu puis les autres voitures ont
également pris feu
il est difficile d'expliquer ce que je
ressens à mettre à gauche ou à droite et
ça aurait pu être mon appartement je
n'ai pas de mots
c'est bombardements russes les plus
importants depuis 6 semaines ont fait
plusieurs morts dirigeons
ukrainiennes ont été touchées parmi
elles vivent dans l'Ouest plutôt
épargnés jusque là ni pro nicolaïve ou
encore zapporisia ou la plus grande
centrale nucléaire du pays a été coupée
du réseau national
de nombreux infrastructures énergétiques
comptent également été visées à travers
toute l'Ukraine laissant des millions de
foyers sans électricité
la nouveauté de ces frappes qualifiées
de misérables tactique par volody
mirzelinski l'utilisation par la Russie
d'au moins s'immicile hypersonique
kingjal une arme que Kiev n'a aucun
moyen d'abattre car le Kinja vole au
moins deux fois plus vite que ses
missiles dédiés à sa défense
anti-aérienne selon les experts ces
missiles hypersoniques Moscou en
posséderait plusieurs dizaines et on
retrouve à Mo